ahora que sabemos que podemos tratar las
unidades como variables algebraicas
vamos a encontrar las unidades de una
fórmula en este caso la fórmula es
igual a b / s al cuadrado y también nos
dicen que está en centímetros y que ese
está en gramos por centímetro cuáles
serán las unidades de acá los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y piensen en ello
vamos a imaginar algunos valores para
ver y para s y veamos qué pasa aquí yo
digo que ve va a ser igual a 1
centímetro y también digo que ese va a
ser igual a un gramo sobre centímetro
obviamente estos valores los elijo por
conveniencia vamos a sustituir estos
valores en la fórmula nos va a quedar
que acá es igual a b y yo definí ve como
un centímetro entre s al cuadrado ese es
un gramo por centímetro por lo que me va
a quedar uno
gramos por centímetro todo esto
al cuadrado ya habíamos hablado de que
podemos manipular las unidades como
variables algebraicas podemos escribir
esto como un centímetro y entre 1 al
cuadrado es 1
/ centímetro todo esto al cuadrado esto
viene de la idea de que a por b al
cuadrado es lo mismo que tener a
cuadrada por b cuadrado y también está
la idea de que si tenemos a entre b todo
esto al cuadrado va a ser igual a tener
al cuadrado entre b al cuadrado por lo
que esto va a ser igual un centímetro
entre uno por un gramos al cuadrado
entre centímetros al cuadrado y sabemos
que esto es lo mismo que tener un
centímetro multiplicado por el recíproco
del denominador por unos centímetros
cuadrados entre gramos al cuadrado bueno
pues sí recuerdo que esto nos puedo
tratar como variables algebraicas
centímetro por centímetro cuadrado esto
va a ser igual a centímetro
hubo entre en gramos al cuadrado y bueno
uno pero no va a ser uno recordemos que
aquí yo inventé los valores debe irse lo
importante aquí son las unidades de la
fórmula cuando ve esta en centímetros y
cuando es ésta en gramos sobre
centímetros pues la fórmula estará en
términos de centímetros cúbicos entre
gramos al cuadrado quien nos dice pues
que esto del centímetro cúbico lo puede
interpretar como volumen va a estar
dividido entre una masa al cuadrado
gramos al cuadrado que no es tan
intuitivo pero estas son las unidades de
campo con estas características